well I'm joined now by the chief
economist for Europe at Standard
Chartered Bank Sarah Hugh in a very good
evening to you Sarah solid performance
then from the UK the Chancellor saying
he was happy with the better than
expected results but still a note of
caution yes we've seen growth declining
over the last year or so and we are
still performing at the weaker end of
our competitors if you look at the OECD
then the UK is is one of the weakest
performers in there in the group and
should we be worried about that I mean
we also heard John McDonald today
pointing out that we're actually
slipping behind Europe in many ways we
have to remember it's not necessarily
comparing like could like we've done a
lot better after the crash than many
European countries there's a huge amount
of quantitative easing going on there we
shouldn't be too downbeat on ourselves
should we know the economy has done
pretty well since the global financial
crisis we were one of the best
performing economies and we are at a
more mature stage of the economic cycle
of course the labour market is strong so
if you look at various other indicators
then it suggests that the economy's is
not doing too badly at all having said
that of course we are seeing a slowdown
in consumer spending we are seeing a
squeeze on wages as a result of high
inflation so there are some concerns
that over the course of the next year
the economic performance may slow
further what about interest rates
everybody seems to be an agreement that
to expect in the Bank of England now to
raise them next week only a fraction
though yes we think that they will raise
interest rates by a quarter of a percent
now if we go back to August of last year
there was an emergency rate cut because
of fears that the brexit vote would
result in a much steeper slowdown in
economic activity the economy has slowed
but not by nearly as much as the Bank of
England feared so they will probably
feel that there they can reverse the
emergency rate cut of last year but they
will want to signal that this is not the
start of a rate hacking cycle I think
it'll be very very gradual very cautious
and they'll be the first since 2007 what
will it mean for ordinary people will it
actually be quite a good thing for
example
say this well it should be a good thing
for savers and of course savers have
faced in incredibly low interest rates
for some time now for people who have
mortgages of course those mortgage costs
these the mortgage servicing is going to
be rising for people who have variable
interest rates so for some people it is
going to be a further squeeze and so
about giving them will be very cautious
about making sure that it doesn't slam
the brakes on too far too fast and cause
a dramatic slowdown in activity Bank of
England will be cautious do you think
the Chancellor will also be cautious
when he's preparing his budget now we
heard him saying earlier look okay the
economy's actually doing better than a
lot of people feared it would after
brexit but pointing out practice hasn't
even really started yet so he's got to
think about all of that manage all of
that with his maneuverings and coming up
with the budget you'll expect that to be
cautious yes he doesn't have a huge
scope for stimulus and there are likely
to be some targeted giveaways some help
maybe for first-time buyers and
addressing some of the intergenerational
issues that the the UK faces and how
will he stimulate productivity crucially
well that is a very very good point
the productivity puzzle has been a real
problem for the economy and nobody quite
knows what to do about it
one aspect could be to boost investment
but of course as we face uncertainty
about brexit businesses may be cautious
about investing so we may not see a
recovery in productivity growth anytime
soon okay so here I'm really good to
talk to you thanks very much indeed